howdy folks in welcome back to
GameSpot's ongoing coverage of e3 2014
i'm here with martin gaston Jim Martin
earlier today we got to play one of the
most hotly anticipated games at the show
Oh for the way your smash brothers for
the wii u a super smash brothers 3d yes
yeah Martin whose fridge smash player
it's Pikachu pick oh oh you're a parable
human BTW i love figure to tell he works
he jumps up and he's small he's hot is
it whitening oh yeah the tension and I
don't like especially when like
someone's on a platform above him and
he's just seven anything aside you know
what I might do i'm gonna summon down
some mother lightning less of you as you
continue to talk so did you get to play
fancy at you at all doing it i did i
said his Pikachu on both the 3ds and wii
u let's start with the wii u version
where g what did you think it was jump
down him it's smash brothers right you
know and it's i didn't play enough brawl
I brawl Salatin broad kind of well kind
of got to me like I didn't yeah I stop
him doing my so I wasn't enjoying boy
the island unless of staff and it felt
kind of random and it was it was just
too it got that sort of mario kart thing
around like I'm winning this game yeah
because I'm winning this game the game's
punishing me for it I'm like oh no no no
no no no this doesn't feel like that
this was way more like back in the day
we're super smash brothers melee you
know back when everyone loved smash
brothers right and even though it'll be
very familiar if you've played at all
you'll pick it up and go here Smash
Brothers which prints tensions game I'm
not very good at so please don't ask me
talk about balance or anything but you
will immediately get that sense that
it's not as it's not as cheap as ruled
to me like it feels more like a go and I
think that's why they're running this
big lug eSports tournament this week so
yeah I feel like they're really
deposition this game is having sort of a
competitive edge whereas i knoe smash
brothers ball especially with with the
tripping mechanic a lot of people hated
that and everything is not going to be
it is a new cities match go on this dad
is out so i will say something I thought
was interesting this has been a previous
smash brothers game
I was playing the wii u version I
noticed a lot coming down on somebody's
head yeah bouncing off of it it seemed
to happen constantly in my time the game
granted I was playing it was exclusively
for person brawls um so maybe that had
something to do with it close quarters
you got so many people but constantly
people were landing on my head I was
leaning other people says it's just like
I don't know the hitboxes for that or
maybe a bit larger just yeah happen a
lot more I definitely like as I know
when you're flying away into the risin
when you coming back you sort of
gravitate back into the action no matter
what I press like and they were just
were 0 into where where the Comets going
I don't know if it's actually doing that
or not but like you know and there was
there was a lot of head mounting so by
that that is a thing that I felt as well
but so did you get to try any of the new
characters I liked the wii fit trainer
very much oh really I enjoy playing as a
wii for trend just because i thought it
was funny stepping on my thunder a
little because i also play a lot of a
wii fit trainer i think i've had a lot
of fun I think the wii fit trainer is
gonna go down very very well by default
it's the female one but he can change
the costumes it sends it to mail week
for training it's like a warrior
situation abroad we have like warrios
microgames outfit and again like it's
classy and worry yeah um we've returned
sort of fun i paid his greninja because
obviously i love pokemon i didn't like
greninja it was to choose to technical
he was flipping around all the place one
of his skills is that he sort of you
know darts quite quickly and I just kept
getting lost on the screen when it was a
full player brawl I just got really god
damn loss so I didn't enjoy that
whatsoever that's a bit of a similar
experience I would I wanted to try out
Little Mac was actually the character I
started with hi Little Mac actually
reminded me of Sonic in a lot of ways
where I pick him up yeah he's so fast
and so brutal yeah you just lose control
them a little bit he's just like she's
taken across a just zip across the
screen there's quite a bit that when you
pick Sonic like if you're not played bro
yeah you will just automatically run off
the edge vs green into the great blue
yonder yeah and you'll be going let L be
minus one to you and you feel like a
right Pratt but um let's let's jump to
the 3ds version yeah unlike the wii u
version 3 s version just had the
the car i think it's called smash run or
something like that yeah a multiplayer
you know free for all setup that we have
for we use yeah single-player sticker
run smash from here smash run is like
there I think it's their 3ds mode right
and so there's a bit where suppose you
go into this like dungeon area and you
can run around and it's I think it's
randomly populated with monsters right I
think it's the same layout but i think
it's randomly populated with monsters
and you you kill them in the monsters
are all based on like classic Nintendo
characters you kill them they drop items
you pick them up and that that boosts
stats of your character so like a boost
your speed or your we're attack power
and then that's like three or four
minutes long maybe i'm not sure i might
be wrong there or it might be like
toggleable i'm over this up how long
these runs off and then after that
amount of time you warp into a fight a
four-person front with your level with
your numbers and stats adjusted what
they were in the run and then you see
who wins based based on that every sort
of things that I saw that we're
interesting about that mode is one there
are special items you can use down on
the second screen so the top screen is
all the action the second screen not
only has like your different stats and
you're leveling up but it also has like
there is a item that lets you shoot a
giant laser just straight across yeah
that's whatever there's an item that
sends out a shock wave that knocks
everyone away from you um miss fun but
it was a lot of but for me it really is
all about a classic you know the you
know the proper fighting of it you know
your pink character three other players
and you fight that's really what it's
about i know they need to put in other
modes but that's you know i play them a
bit really it's defying and i'm sure i'm
sure you're the same deep down i am deep
down i mean i understand it for the
handheld I imagine a lot of that is
going to be you know you're mostly
playing by yourself or you know maybe
with one of the person on here something
like that so I'm glad they have these
sorts of modes in there for the handheld
version but I think we're gonna go ahead
and wrap it up there it's fun it's smash
brothers it is fun it's nice to us in
its bun thank you folks for watching of
course you stay tuned to gamespot com
for our ongoing III 2014 coverage I'm
actually this is Martin we'll see you
next time
you